we brought a hundred and fifty Devils in
from the wild they are placed across a
number of zoos and wildlife parks large
free-range enclosures where Devils can
live in a semi natural environment but
still at much higher density than they
do in the wild breed up and live in a
natural state these are all components
of what we call an insurance population
and it's an insurance meta population
there are many small populations so if
the disease gets into one we can still
save the Tasmanian devil in others the
point of the devil insurance program and
devil Ark is to keep Devils safe in
captivity for their release to the wild
when deemed necessary now one of the
most critical components of that is that
Devils remain as wild Devils
behaviorally that we can take a devil
from devil Ark put it back into the
Tasmanian wilderness and it survives it
knows how to find food it knows how to
breed it knows where water is it knows
how to find shoulder it's critical that
we retain those wild behaviors